نفى الكريم ان يكون الهدف من زياره الرئيس
بوتين الى بيلاروسيا هو اشتراك مينسك في
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا من
جهته قال الرئيس الروسي في مؤتمر صحفي مع
نظيره البيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكاشينكو انه
بحث خلال الزياره انشاء مجال دفاعيا موحد
بين البلدين
اقتراح رئيسي بلا روسيا لتدريب اطقم
الطائرات المقاتله التابعه للجيش بلا
روسيا والتي تم تحويلها بالفعل من اجل
الاستخدام المحتمل للذخيره التي تطلق من
الجو براس الحربي اتفقنا على تنفيذ عمليه
تسليما متبادله من الاسلحه المطلوبه
والمشاركه في انتاج معدات عسكريه جديده
ومواصله التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تقوم بانشطه
مماثله مع حلفائها داخل كتله النيته منذ
عقود هذه الاجراءات المنسقه مهمه للغايه
فيما يتعلق بالوضع المتوتر على الحدود
الخارجيه لدوله الاتحاد
من جهه اكد الرئيس البيلاروسيا الكسندر
لوكيشن كونشرا منظومات صواريخ اس 400
واسكندر روسيه الصنع على الاراضي
البيلاروسيا وقال لوكشينكو في المؤتمر
الصحفي مع نظير الروسي انه لا يمكن لبلاده
ضمان امنيه دون مساعده روسيا
[موسيقى]
انطلاقا من الوضع الحالي على طول الحدود
ناقشنا بعض التفاصيل المهمه للتعاون في
مجال الامن العسكري وضعنا في الخدمه
منظومه اس 400 التي سلمتموها الى
بيلاروسيا ومنظومه صواريخ اسكندر التي
وعدتمونا بها قبل سته اشهر سلمت لنا ايضا
باستخدامها عند الحاجه لاداء الواجب
القتاليه هذه الاعمال
في الغرب يتدربون على تحميل رؤوس الحربيه
النوويه اطلب منكم التفكيره في الرد على
هذه الاشياء الرجاء مساعدتنا على الاقل في
تكييف الطائرات التي لدينا والتي يمكنها
حمل اسلحه نوويه